so let's let's let's keep moving to some
of the other things that are going on we
probably have a lot of college alum
alums here we've got you know the
wonderful opportunity to say hello to
our Dean Jim valentini who's in the
audience here today Jim just kind of
stand up and raise your hand we had Lee
had a difficult August II with you know
a resignation of our current Dean and
and you know there was some discussion
among the alums that there were if there
was a lot of commitment to the college
and the core need-blind admissions and
financial aid etc and Jim came in today
with a lot of support from Lee and made
a great presentation solely talk a
little bit about you know the college
and its importance in the university but
we all know that the college the
undergraduates that we do absolutely
central to the University and part of
that experience that we regard as so
crucial is the core curriculum it's one
of the great great inventions of by
Columbia it is unique in the United
States it could never be repeated today
for a variety of reasons at any other
University in part because it's actually
very very expensive to mount every
single year but we're committed to it
it's it's great and the student
satisfaction with it is as high as it's
ever been we're also very proud to be
one of a handful of institutions that
lives by the principle of need-blind
admissions so if you come from a family
that cannot afford to come to come to
columbia we will pay all of your
expenses if you're sixty thousand
dollars are less than your family and
very generous financial aid above that
as well we have great students we want
to keep great students the faculty are
deeply committed to this all of this is
not going to change we're not ever going
to change the commitment to the core
curriculum and we're not going to change
the commitment to need
blind admissions or to getting the very
best students from the United States and
around the world the like any part of
the University we really want to always
be involved in trying to think about how
to improve it improvement is the essence
of university and debate and engagement
with faculty and with students and with
alums about how to do things better is
what created the core curriculum in the
first place and what will keep it alive
in the future so how do you educate a
student in today's global world ready to
understand what's happening in China
India other countries around the world
how do we do that how do we integrate
that into the undergraduate experience
and including the core curriculum these
are the kinds of issues we should take
up and will take up but the essence is
unchangeable so you know what I remember
coming back and meeting you the first
summer you took over and you one of the
observations you had is that Filipinos
landlocked and that we needed to do
something about that an over a period of
years you know what you had took a
vision of expanding the campus to the
north to wear today manhattanville is
real talk about that a little bit some
of it being your vision and what you see
being there and what progress are making
I'm sure that a lot of people know and
they're probably others from other parts
of the of the country in the world that
really haven't seen it know exactly what
it's all about so Columbia of course
begins in this history of Colombian
space and the modern era begins in 1968
and that's the year of course of the
gymnasium controversy and that was so
rancorous and so problematic for the
university that in the years and decades
after that as Colombia used up as we
used up our space on Morningside Heights
and up in Washington Heights we simply
did not have
the opportunity to build as knowledge
grows as faculty and students need more
space we just couldn't do it as well
universities grow believe it or not on
average about a million square feet
every decade that's just what you have
to have in order to be a vibrant
University Columbia couldn't do this in
in the 1990s the NIH budget was doubled
in the our Medical Center our basic
science has really depend upon the NIH
and we fell because we couldn't expand
to take advantage of the new money from
NIH from about fifth are sixth in the
country to 14th or 15th where we are
today that's an unacceptable result for
a great university so these were real
real problems we were facing so we
decided I decided very early on not to
fight this building by building block or
you know just space lot by lot but to
take on a big big idea of a whole new
campus nearby 18 acres which is actually
what originally we had coming from
midtown up to Morningside Heights 17
acres and we would try to get rezoning
and eminent domain if needed but
hopefully not we would try to get
rezoning for the entire 18 acres at one
time and do a campus we went in with 17
mil a 7 million square feet of space
that we wanted on these 18 acres we
promised to take care of every single
resident who lived there and fortunately
the space between 125th and one 33rd
broadway and twelfth Avenue had only a
couple of hundred people who lived there
we promised everyone they would have a
better life than that and we proceeded
to negotiate with 33 of the 36 property
owners successfully and then the final
three we had to deploy or rely on the
state for eminent domain those are not
local residents we said we would never
use eminent domain against the property
against residents but only against
property that was owned by people
outside the community and
as in this case and as of a year ago
that process was successful and we now
have rezone this entire 18 acres we
never have to go back again for
approvals this is this is an astonishing
thing in Manhattan to have this space in
which to build so so give the audience a
little feel for what what schools are
going to be down there and you know and
how you view that the primary there so
in the process of trying also to deal
with our immediate needs especially for
our scientists in arts and sciences and
we can talk also about how we try to
help the Medical Center but for our arts
and sciences sciences and our seas
engineers we built the last building on
the Morningside Heights campus 115 years
after Seth lo laid the cornerstone for
low library that's the so-called
northwest corner building and we're
still looking for a naming gift for that
that's why it's called northwest corner
you have any ideas got to give us call
it is not mr. and mrs. northwest corner
name and we have wonderful
interdisciplinary groups in there now
that building designed by rafael moneo
the great spanish architect looks north
as well as inward and columbia completes
a space that's extremely beautiful now
looks north to the new Morningside
Heights campus in four years from now
possibly five but I'm determined to make
it for a four hundred thousand square
foot fantastic laboratory facility built
by Renzo Piano designed by Renzo Piano
will open and we will have in it the
greatest interdisciplinary group in the
world working on mind brain behavior the
neuroscience led by Eric Kendall Richard
axle and Tom
gesell the first do being Nobel Prize
winners they will lead a really
unbelievable group of neuro scientists
and then related disciplines economics
law biophysics and statistics and so on
that will be unmatched any place in the
world next to it will be the School of
the Arts and Carol Becker's a wonderful
Dean I noticed her and some of these
trips that have been taken and she's
leading the School of the Arts to locate
in manhattanville and then a new
conference center that will be the first
that Club be has four major events sepa
school of international public affairs
will be next to the School of the Arts
and then just north will be the business
school the engineering school is also
planning for a building there that only
takes up a third of just a fraction of
what's now available which we leave for
future chairs of the trustees and
presidents of the university to talk
about at CAA meetings if you up if you
have a chance while you're here you know
over this weekend oh look at you get
down there you should look you should
look at it and we have other trustees
carry out its accomplice I see is in the
room I don't know if Philip milstein
they handle you know what we used to
call buildings and grounds physical
assets and have really good
understanding of everything that's being
built there and how it's being built but
this is a product of it of a nine-year
vision by our president that right now
is tangible you can touch it the
approvals are there and the buildings
are being built